So virtual networks have various design goals. It
should be flexible, able to support different topologies,
routing and forwarding architectures and independent configurations. They
should be manageable, in other words, they should separate
the policy that a network operator is trying
to specify from the mechanisms of how those policies
are implemented. They should be scalable, maximizing the
number or coexisting virtual networks. They should be secure
by isolating the different logical networks from
one another. They should be programmable and
they should be heterogenious in the sense
that they should support different technologies. So virtual
networks have two components, nodes and edges.
The physical nodes themselves must be virtualized. One
possible way virtualizing a node is a
virtual machine. A more lightweight way of virtualizing
a node is using a virtual environment such as a VServer or a Jail.
The hypervisor or whatever technology is enabling
the virtual environment can effectively slice the
underlying physical hardware to provide the allusion
of multiple guest nodes or multiple virtual
nodes. Examples of node virtualization include, virtual
machine environment such as Xen or VMware or
what's called OS level virtualization or virtual environments,
such as Linux Vservers. Now, in a virtual network,
we need to connect these virtual machines. Each
virtual machine or virtual environment has its own view
of the network stack. And we may want
to provide the appearance that these nodes are connected
to one another over a Layer two topology,
even if they are in fact separated by multiple
IP hops. One possible way of doing that is to encapsulate the Ethernet packet as
it leaves the VM on the left in an IP packet. The IP packet can then be destined
for the IP address of the machine on
the right, and when the packet arrives at this
machine, the host can decapsulate the packet and
pass the original Ethernet packet to the VM or
the virtual environment that's residing on that physical
node. Each of one these physical hosts, may
in fact, host multiple virtual machines or virtual
environments, which creates the need for a virtual
switch that resides on a physical host. This
virtual switch provides the function of networking virtual
machines together over a virtual layer two topology.
The Linux bridge is an example of a software
switch that can perform this type of function.
Open Vswitch is another example of software that performs
this type of glue function. You can see more
information about Open Vswitch on the URL provided here.